make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I am currently in a hotel right
now and the reason why I'm in a hotel
will be made apparent on my vlog new
channel but we are recording the audio
for Doctor Strange the technically I'm
supposed to be on vacation like really I
am but like you know the video I had
scheduled came out today so in the the
last video on Doctor Strange we had
talked about how like Galactus it
basically can soon Dormammu right like
basically like taking over the energies
of Dormammu and then sucked him into
himself right and this basically
elevated Galactus to like a whole new
level of power right he was essentially
like God no animals is kind of
interesting if there was an eternity for
the the magical dimension right for all
the space that makes up the various
magical dimensions then it would have
been Galactus after he had consumed that
he was just so astronomically powerful
and so the result was that dr. strange
handled all of his magical energy into a
single hit and then attacked Galactus
and when he did the belief was that he
destroyed everything but what ended up
happening is instead he was met with
this giant white void now at that point
he's met with the living embodiment of
eternity and this is under normal
circumstances not supposed to happen and
here's the reason why eternity is in and
of itself the answer to the question
what if like all the life in the
universe everything that represented all
life could get up and walk around
that would be eternity and so in a giant
white void when there is essentially
nothing eternity should not exist but
Doctor Strange exists therefore eternity
is a reflection of Doctor Strange he's
basically a reflection of existence now
you would think eternity would take the
form of Doctor Strange if that were the
case and if it chose to it could um but
eternity has its own form and that's the
reason why he appears the way he does
but what it asked Stephen strange is
what in the heck happened here and the
response of Stephen was to basically say
well the belief was that that Galactus
would be destroyed and one it would be
the end of him in the main Marvel
Universe and two it would bring an end
to all the magical threat that exists
out there and like all these crazy
magical dimensions where Galactus was
going nuts what what eternity ends up
revealing this Stephen strange is that's
not what happened instead what took
place is that what Stephen strange did
was essentially destroy the universe and
then reset it there's this tiny little
singularity at the very beginning of
everything - it's essentially like it's
frozen in a moment like it's frozen in
time for a second but what's basically
happening here is Stephen strange hikky
locked is destroyed Galactus Galactus
imploded sucked everything in on himself
and basically gave birth to like a new
universe and so this is kind of the
moment before the universe explodes in
the Big Bang and becomes something
wholly new and
kind of a big deal because the question
that's asked here is how did that happen
right like how did we get to that point
where it ended up being like Doctor
Strange who reset everything and that's
what we end up or at least Doctor
Strange seems to indicate that it was
the intention of Mephisto right it was
the the grand plan of Mephisto to
essentially reset all of reality but
then we end up finding out that's not
true it's not what my fit still wanted
that Mephisto is realm of hell resides
on souls right I mean we've talked about
that before but for those are guys who
were new here Mephisto is kind of a
stand-in for Satan or at least he was
until al Ewing introduced the one below
all name credible whole comics
um but Mephisto was kind of this being
who would basically trick people it's
like he would come to you in a time of
need in a time of dire and say I can
help you out of this situation I can
give you what you want all I'm going to
do is ask for something in return and if
you choose to barter with him two things
will happen the first is that you'll get
what you want but then you'll get
something that handicaps it you'll say
like man like you I really wish I had
like a million dollars I mean I'm in
desperate need of like being able to pay
off my house or something along those
lines
and so my Vista would give you the money
to have your house paid off and then as
soon as your house is paid off if you
like destroyed it storm and then the
other thing is when you die he'll take
your soul he's a pretty bad guy having
said that he's also supremely powerful
but like appearing here to Stephen
strange and just being like you screw
everything up you destroyed Galactus you
screwed everything up this fraction of a
moment when Mephisto ended up yanking
dr. strange to his room Mephisto is far
more powerful than Doctor Strange and
that's the reason why Stephen strange
doesn't really cause me any beef with
Mephisto right I mean under ending
almost circumstance if Mephisto had been
away from his own realm long enough like
Doctor Strange could start some stuff
and so when is it happening is Mephisto
kind of turns to him and says well you
know he starts to think and he says well
if you had the ability to basically fix
the universe would you do it and Doctor
Strange says yes and this is important
because Doctor Strange had made a deal
with Mephisto he'd made a pact with him
he would seek help from a Fisto to free
Umar and and Clea who Mephisto had taken
Ryo and Galactus was going crazy
Doctor Strange made a barter with
Mephisto they hey I'll come calling for
a favor later on and in return I will
release Clea and and whom are at the
moment so that's what that's exactly
Mephisto did so this seems to basically
be the the request being made on the
fist oh is fix everything as it was kind
of crazy because when that happened
Steven strand says well I can't just do
it willy-nilly because there's judges
out there there's people that want to
make sure that the cosmic balance is
being maintained and that's when you're
met by the arrival of the Living
Tribunal and this is kind of a cool
thing because under normal circumstances
the Living Tribunal would probably
look at this and say I see no error here
right in terms like what happened a
conflict broke out and a being attained
insane amount of power and what the
destruction of that being came the birth
of a new universe it's the natural order
of things and so the results of this is
that the Living Tribunal initially seeks
to ask dr. strange what's your
motivation behind this like are you
going to recreate the universe and then
fancy yourself a God or are you going to
recreate the universe as it was and of
course what he ends up saying is I'm
going to recreate it as it was and the
reason why is because if Stephen strange
decided to make himself a god like make
himself the god of the universe he would
stand side by side with eternity best
magical imbalance it's a mystical
imbalance in the universe and the Living
Tribunal would never allow that to
happen in the exact same way that when
Adam warlock sought to become when he
got the Infinity Gauntlet at the end of
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline and he
saw to rule alongside eternity that the
Living Tribunal said this is a cosmic
imbalance you cannot have two absolute
beings in the universe well you can't
have two supreme beings in the universe
it doesn't work that way you could only
have one and that's exactly what the
tribunal says you can do what you want
to do like you can fix the universe just
make sure that everything goes back
exactly the way that it was before
and that's exactly what ends up
happening it's kind of a crazy thing
because what's basically going on here
is Stephen strange destroyed the
universe and then we made it and the
difference here is that he's remaking it
exactly the way that it was before now
the reality is is if I'm being honest
here it's not really a letdown for me
it's not really a disappointment for me
and the reason why is because what you
basically get is this this kind of is
it's really more like a focus on on
Stephen strange right like the price is
Stephen strange has to pay for for the
magic that he wields and then the role
he plays which is the biggest
undertaking he's ever seen basically
recreating all of existence now if this
was a big crossover event then I'd be
pissed I'd be mad because I'd be like
well this is just a lazy way to end it
it's just a really lazy way to end the
event but for me it's not really a lazy
way to end the story it's basically
saying that like Stephen strange is the
sorcerer supreme this is his job it's
his job to do things like this and so to
me that's why it works because it's the
nature of his character I think it works
I think it fits in perfectly one of the
other cool things that comes out of this
is remember like when it comes to to the
universe it has to be made perfectly
which means necessity and so this
basically means the return of all these
dark beings vanos mistress death like
all these terrible characters who've
existed over the years and done and and
committed heinous acts as it was kind of
a cool little moment because when that
happens you basically have him having to
like relive his life like relive all his
past mistakes the fact that he was he
was an amazing surgeon the fact that his
arrogance got the better
that he accidentally drove off a cliff
he ended up losing the ability to use
his hands and then he became the
sorcerer supreme he has to go back and
relive all these mistakes he made all
these battles that he fought and it'd be
very very easy for him to kind of go
back and say well maybe I didn't drive
off a cliff you know maybe I my
arrogance didn't get the better of me or
you know this maybe this happened maybe
that happens along those lines maybe I
can make spider-man's life a little bit
better but the issue is who knows what
effect it will have on the universe what
he's basically doing here because he's
molding at any change he makes will
affect this universe it won't create a
branch off universe it will affect the
future of this universe and so if he
decided not to fly off the bridge and if
he decided that he basically went on to
continue to become an amazing surgeon
then it could create like this totally
bleak and dark future where everything
is ruled by Baron Mordo who knows what
kind of reality that would possess
instead what he does is he goes back to
this moment when you ended up having
bozo laws show up and and basically
initiate this whole thing right because
remember it was Zola's who showed up
after Galactus had basically you know
threatened his planet or at least was
believed to be on the way to consume its
planet and then in turn like it was
Doctor Strange being a little hottie
being a little arrogant and then like
Zola taking off and then whisking
Galactus into the magical dimension that
led to all this in the first place and
so what he does is he casts an inch an
enchantment spell on his own laws and
basically says like this is the nature
of the beast like you are now contained
and instead of being the person that
says like whoa sorry about your luck man
there's really nothing you could do you
know and kind of putting Zola's in a
position to where he was desperate and
believe that he just had to get rid of
Galactus in order to make it work
instead Stephen strange reasons with it
and notice this this is actually kind of
a cool concept one of the things he says
here is he says that whenever it was a
Galactus showed up on earth that he was
always sent away but no two
circumstances ever worked the same now
that is true to a degree but the the
ultimate nullifier kind of flies in the
face of that by the ultimate nullifier
being this device that anything you
pointed at and pull the trigger on it'll
basically kind of wipe it from existence
as if it was never there in the first
place right and so but for the most part
they're right
whenever Galactus shows up and and tries
to consume the world it's always a
different reason for why he ends up
leaving and so that's basically what it
is that that Doctor Strange tells me as
he says there was one point work a lot
to shuttle to a planet called Zin Locke
and basically consumed or at least was
going to consume the world until a guy
named Norrin Radd
chose to become Galactus Herald and
instead he would basically seek out
world and Galactus would spare his and
so that's the statement that he really
makes - Zola's is this is really the
only option you have to basically
surrender yourself
become Galactus new Herald spear your
world but go forward helping him find
other worlds following his meeting with
the Living Tribunal and eternity both of
whom approve avoid of the work he's done
the fact that everything's back to
normal and it's essentially like nothing
ever happens at all he suddenly whisked
away by Mephisto and this is when we get
to like the really duplicitous side of
Mephisto right because what he says is
no no no you still owe me a favor
and when Stephen strain says yeah but I
remade the universe just like you asked
miffy so says I I never actually asked
you to do that I never actually made
that a request I simply presented the
situation to you and that's how math
Fisto works you have to be very
meticulous in terms of what he says and
how he says it and no point in his
dealings with dr. strange did he say
then I'm asking you to read to fix the
universe I'm asking you to set
everything back to the way that it was
before he never did that you know
because that um it's kind of interesting
Mark Waid sort of yanked the spider man
one more day Ching in this scenario what
he basically says is I want a faction of
a soul like I want a fraction of a soul
that exists out there and so it's kind
of crazy because well we're not really
explicitly told what it is what it seems
to be is a fraction of clea soul right
like the ex-wife of Stephen strange
because when he shows up there he
basically asked her like do you believe
there's a chance for us to start over do
you believe there's a chance for us to
find romantic happiness once again and
Clea is like absolutely I do I've always
thought about that why are you asking me
and he's like because I was hoping you
would give me a different answer and
then basically that's your mind like
wipes away her memories of him she has
no idea who Stephen strange is now in
reality if you're not a fan of Stephen
strange this moment will pass without
any real measure of value you're just
gonna be like okay I mean I guess that's
the thing but if you are fan of Stephen
strange I don't know how you'll take it
whether you'll be mad or whether you'll
be happy I honestly don't really care
clear never really interested me that
much in the first place but it is kind
of interesting I imagine for a hardcore
Doctor Strange fans this is like a
Spider Man one more day kind of thing um
just not as you know as impactful or as
big because Doctor Strange is in Spider
Man but still you know it's kind of an
interesting moment because it's
basically Doctor Strange going back to
the path of being alone going back to
the passages of it just being him and
nobody else is intriguing here it's
really really interesting but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come as explained make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you